Welcome to Man Does Tech, where I solve
the problems you didn't even know you
had.
>> In this video, I will explain how to
program a Honda Civic key fob. First,
gather all key fobs you intend to
program, including any that currently
work. Make sure your car battery is
fully charged to avoid interruptions.
This process involves a specific
sequence of steps that must be followed
carefully. We'll walk through each part
to ensure your new or replacement key
fob functions correctly. It's a
straightforward process once you
understand the timing. To begin, sit in
the driver's seat and ensure all doors
are securely closed. Insert your key
into the ignition and turn it to the on
position, but do not start the engine.
Within 4 seconds of turning the key,
press the lock button on one of the key
fobs you wish to program. This action
helps initiate the vehicle's programming
mode. You'll hear a distinct click or
sound confirming entry. Now, turn the
key to the off position, then
immediately back to on within 4 seconds.
Again, press the lock button on the same
key fob within 4 seconds. You need to
repeat this entire on, off, on, lock
sequence two more times. The car's door
locks will cycle, indicating successful
entry into the programming phase. This
confirms the vehicle is ready to learn
the key fob signal. Once the locks
cycle, press the lock button on every
key fob you want to program, including
any existing ones, within 10 seconds.
The locks will cycle again after each
successful registration. After
programming all fobs, turn the ignition
key to the off position to exit the
programming mode. Test each key fob to
ensure all functions like lock and
unlock work correctly. Remember to check
the description for a link to the OALA
water bottle and other great deals.
Thanks for watching. If you found this
helpful, don't forget to like and
subscribe.